the Joe Rogan experience here we go
great to see you and congratulations
thank you you will never forget what is
going on in the world when you think
about when your child is born you will
know for the rest of this child's life
you were born during a weird time that's
for sure yeah that is for sure they're
probably the weirdest that I can
remember yeah yeah and he was born on
may the 4th and that's lares - yeah
fourth be with him yeah exactly has to
be hopeful I sure hope so
perfect yes I mean that was the perfect
day for you I'm yeah but how do you say
the name well a placeholder and first of
all my partner's the one that actually
mostly came up with the name
congratulations to her yeah yeah she's
very named so I mean it's just X the
letter X and then the AE is like
pronounced ash yeah and then a 12 a 12
is my contribution o ye 12 Archangel 12
the precursor to the sr-71 coolest plane
ever I I agree with you I don't know I'm
not familiar with it I know one is yeah
yeah yeah I know what that is
so the sr-71 came from a CIA program
called called Archangel oh it's the
Archangel project and then Archangel 12
wow what a dope look compliant yeah oh
yeah well as a person who's very much
into aerial travel as you are well
that's perfect it's pretty great
yeah pretty great so is it does it feel
strange to have a child while this
craziness is going does it feeling
you've had children before is this any
weirder it's actually I think it's
better being older and having a kid I
appreciate it more hmm yeah babies are
awesome they are pretty awesome they're
awesome yeah but I didn't have any of my
own I would see other people's kids and
I didn't not like that sure but I wasn't
drawn to them sure but now when I see
little people's kids I'm like oh I think
of a middle of packages yeah a little
Vogue's yeah it's just you you think of
them differently when you see them come
out and then grow and then eventually
start talking to you like your whole
idea what a baby is is very different
yeah so now as you you know get older
and get to appreciate it as a mature
fully formed adult it must be really
pretty wonderful yeah wonderful that's
great for babies are awesome yeah yeah
that's uh that's great
yeah I mean also I I've spent a lot of
time on AI and neural nets and so you
can sort of see then kind of the brain
develop which is you know what an annual
neural net is trying to simulate what a
brain does basically and you can sort of
see the it learning very quickly you
know it's just wow see things fight so
you're talking about the neural net
you're not talking about an actual baby
interpretation an actual baby but both
of them yes but the word neural net
comes from the the brain it's like a net
of neurons so you know it's like the
yeah humans are the you know
[Laughter]
[Applause]